Eighty percent filthy.
That's how much energy
the American population still derives
from fossil fuels.
Deployment of clean energy,
even at today's rapidly accelerating pace,
is simply not enough
to halt the climate crisis.
Going forward,
if we're going to reduce the risk
of overshoot of global temperature
beyond two degrees C,
we also have to reduce the amount
of CO2 that remains in the atmosphere.
The team I lead, the US Department
of Energy's Office of Science,
is part of an unprecedented
national effort
to get us to net-zero emissions by 2050.
To achieve our goals,
we're aiming to establish
a transformative ecosystem of innovation
that achieves major innovations
in science and technology
for carbon dioxide removal.
Innovations and policy and regulations
to enable the nascent sector
on carbon dioxide removal to grow
and innovations to engage more people
in our quest to finding
and implementing sweeping solutions.
We need major breakthroughs
across multiple arenas,
and we need it fast.
So how do we go about this?
Energy Earthshots.
The Biden-Harris administration's
Earthshot initiative
is inspired by President Kennedy's
Moonshot initiative
that aimed to land a man on the moon.
I think that's a perfect model
for what we need to achieve here.
To achieve the goals
of the Moonshot initiative,
the nation needed to establish a new,
expansive ecosystem of innovation
in space technologies.
It required an all-hands-on-deck approach
that included government,
included educators,
private sector, industry
and, of course, scientists
and engineers and more.
Now with the Department of Energy,
we're launching a similarly
ambitious effort
to enable a portfolio of approaches
that range from basic science
to application of science
to technology development
and for large-scale deployment.
These approaches are needed
to balance the benefits,
trade offs and limitations
of several climate
and clean energy pathways
that are needed to accelerate the timeline
for achieving the solutions that we need.
We've launched seven Earthshots so far.
But as a soil scientist,
I'm particularly excited to tell you today
about the Carbon Negative Shot.
This shot depends
on a strong science foundation
to enable durable,
scalable and responsible carbon dioxide
removal from the atmosphere
at a cost of less than 100 dollars
per metric ton of CO2 equivalent,
including accounting for full life cycle
of emissions within a decade.
But we need to be able
to measure and verify it too.
Achieving the goals
of the Carbon Negative Shot
requires that we advance
and employ nature-based solutions
and engineer new technologies.
On one hand,
we get to learn from nature
to enhance the ability of plants
to take up atmospheric CO2
and promote soil carbon sequestration,
which we can enable
via land use change and land management.
On the other hand,
we aim to advance fundamental material
and chemical sciences
to develop capabilities
for energy-efficient capture
of CO2 from dilute sources.
This includes development
of direct air capture sorbents
for ambient CO2
and systems that are needed
to durably store the captured carbon.
But that's not all we need.
We also need a human-centered component
to the Carbon Negative Shot
to ensure an equitable transition
towards a decarbonized energy system.
We need to make sure
that we realize the full benefits
of all these capabilities
we're putting out.
And in addition to removing
legacy CO2 from the atmosphere,
the goals that we're pursuing
as part of the Carbon Negative Shot
also have multiple potential
additional co-benefits,
including improving soil health
for communities who depend on soil
for their livelihood,
reducing air pollution
and creation of good jobs.
But to realize all these benefits,
we need to make sure that people
from all walks of life are at the table
when critical decisions are being made
about our climate goals
and how we achieve these goals.
For me, as an academic,
and now a leader for a major
science agency for the nation,
this means we need to significantly
revamp our support
for broadening participation
efforts in STEM.
We need to continue to contribute towards
building a vibrant STEM workforce
for the nation.
A workforce that will abide
by principles of environmental justice
at every step of the process.
We need this to make sure
that the science we're enabling
works for society.
Achieving our global climate goals
requires rapid acceleration
of deployment of clean energy
and innovations in carbon dioxide removal.
I'm convinced the Earthshots
are our best shot for achieving our goals.
Just like the Moonshot
landed us on the Moon,
ahead of schedule.
And any success that we register
on these efforts
will not just contribute to removing
legacy CO2 from the atmosphere
and halting the climate crisis.
It will also contribute
to building a better,
more equitable and cleaner world.
Thank you.
(Applause)